[Music]
well compared to the rates in the 80s
and early 90s crime overall is down in
this country but rampage shooters are
increasingly common and they're killing
more people obviously almost all of them
are young men the question which for
some reason very few people ask but as
the key question is what's driving this
surge in extreme antisocial violence one
man who's been thinking about it a lot
he's Jordan Peterson
he's a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto and he just spoke
with us moments ago here it is Jordan
Peterson thanks for joining us tonight
my pleasure we wanted to ask you the
question that we think too few are
asking which is why is this happening
why are young men shooting up schools
because they're nihilistic and desperate
how'd they get that way well I think
life can make you that way unless you
have a purpose and a destiny let's say I
mean there's no shortage of suffering
and malevolence in life and it's easy
for people to become embittered by that
and if they don't see a way out we'll
see a way forward they get angry about
it and and turn against life itself and
they make a display of their hatred for
being by massacring the innocent that's
what's happening and it's a right that
they do right that it's accelerating yes
the the the reserve of guns has and
we've had semi-automatic rifles for a
hundred years but we haven't had this
number of school shootings so the
attitudes are changing I think it's fair
to say what kind of it's also kind of a
psychological epidemic you know these
people keep track of each other and
there's a competitive element to it and
the fact that the media insists upon
publicizing the names of these shooters
is not helpful because part of what
drives them is motivation for notoriety
because we need a idea is better than
being ignored
so what mistakes do you think we're
making as a society to produce an
ever-increasing number of young men like
this that's a good question I think we
underestimate the necessity for young
people to have
direction and a sense of purpose in
their life they need something to offset
the the tragedy and and malevolence of
life and we need to take these sorts of
philosophical and even religious issues
seriously but we don't do you think
we're taking them less seriously than we
used to
yes definitely I think that that we
talked in the past we spoke much more
about responsibility and and and
responsibilities in particular but also
purpose and maturity and we valued those
things highly we didn't confuse them
with tyranny and toxic masculinity for
example yeah
why is it all boys well boys are more
aggressive than girls and there's a
biological component to that that's
quite strong that's why the vast
majority of people in prison are male
like on average there's not much
difference in aggression between men and
women if you picked a random woman and a
random man out of the population and you
had to bet on who is the most aggressive
if you bet it was the woman you'd be
right 40 percent of the time but if you
take the one in 100 most aggressive
people and those would be the people in
prison they're all men or virtually all
men it's also why males commit males
attempt suicide less frequently but they
commit it successfully much more
frequently they're much more likely to
use lethal means and so and there's a
very powerful biological component to
that despite what the post modern social
constructionists have to say about it
but they've got their head firmly buried
in the sand so ya know their resistance
to the evidence in reality we know that
so but given that we know that boys are
the ones if there is a school shooting
who are gonna be the ones committing it
overwhelmingly shouldn't we be thinking
about how to raise our boys in a way
that they're less likely to do this yeah
I think we should be thinking about that
I mean the book I published here this 12
rules for life is a meditation on
exactly that I've been lecturing online
about the the idea that responsibility
is what gives life meaning and that that
meaning is the antidote to the sort of
nihilism
and and aggression and resentment that
can otherwise be produced I mean there's
no doubt that life is difficult and that
people get hurt and betrayed that's
that's that's unassailable truth you
need something to offset that and most
people find that in in their destiny and
their adoption of responsibility and
their willingness to make their own
lives better and the lives of their
families better and to contribute to the
community em to bear bear the burden of
being nobly and that works and but we we
don't we don't think that way anymore
you mentioned the toxic toxic
masculinity I'm not exactly sure what
that means but I've heard the phrase a
lot what what does it mean in our in our
public conversation when someone that
tributes the shootings of toxic
masculinity well it's an attempt to
smear the idea of masculinity by
confusing masculine competence with
tyranny and it's part of the underlying
idea that our culture is a corrupt
tyrannical patriarchy that was run by
men for the advantage of men which is a
very pathological way of looking at the
world but a very common one and if if
that description is accepted then it
means that masculine energy so to speak
whether it's manifested by women or by
men that masculine energy does nothing
but prop up the the tyranny of the
patriarchy and so should not be fostered
and the only people who think that way
are women whose relationships with men
have been extraordinarily damaged or men
who are have no idea who they are or who
are trying to shirk responsibility the
idea that masculinity in its essence is
somehow toxic is an absolutely dreadful
idea I'm glad I asked you that question
Jordan Pederson thank you